le marché du carbone est un système de
vente aux enchères d'unités d'émissions
de gaz à effet de serre compliqué voici
un exemple
cet ingénieur de montréal a construit un
système de traitement de méthane dans
une mine de charbon en alabama pour
vendre des crédits carbone à une grosse
pétrolière en californie il a fait sa
grâce au marché québec californie de
carbone en place depuis le 1er janvier
la mine de charbon jim waters sont
source de beaucoup aidé en alabama
aimait beaucoup de méthane un gaz
dangereux
c'est le fameux grisons pour diminuer
son empreinte d'émissions de gaz à effet
de serre doit s'en débarrasser et s'est
basé sur une technologie québécoise en
installer l'usm locaux avec la recherche
développement d'environ signant d'alain
lusine de la compagnie biothermica
montréal détruit le méthane ce qui lui
donne des crédits de carbone qu'elle
peut revendre à une autre compagnie
pétrolière par exemple qui dépasse ses
limites d'émissions et qui ne veut pas
payer d'amendé à l'état de californie la
californie s'est engagée à ramener ses
émissions de co2 au niveau de celles de
québec veut les baisser de 20% en
dessous du niveau de 1990
lizeroux 1 vient ainsi de vendre plus de
80 mille tonnes de crédits carbone à 12
dollars la tonne sur le marché actuel
c'est un prix plancher garanti total
huit cent soixante mille dollars
il aura amorti rapidement son
investissement c'est la naissance d'un
tout nouveau type d'industrie qui ne
produit rien mais qui élimine la
pollution il ya un marché régional fort
maintenant il faut saluer on peut le
dire
l'avant gardisme du québec d'avoir créé
une telle bourse avec la californie
parce que ça permet à une compagnie
comme biothermica d'investir de l'argent
le prendre des risques de créer de
l'emploi en même temps de vendre des
crédits en californie de rapatrier cet
argent lui au québec
donc tout le monde est gagnant
pour comprendre le marché du carbone il
faut s'imaginer que le monde est un
immense marché composé d' usine qui
génère du co2 certaines usines qui se
modernise par exemple arrive à réduire
leurs émissions co2 et peuvent ainsi
revendre leurs crédits de carbone leur
part non utilisés à des usines qui
dépasse les limites permises
les crédits de carbone obtenus par des
compagnies comme biothermica seront
revendus à des pollueurs
lors de ventes aux enchères strictement
supervisé par la western climate
initiative
il faut comprendre également que les
deux marchés sont liés maintenant depuis
2014 par un accord à travers ce que ce
qu'on appelle la baston climate
initiative qui permet autant groupe de
grands émetteurs québécois d'acheter des
crédits dans quelle est fourni tout
comme ça permet un groupe de grands
émetteurs américains d'acheter des
crédits réalisés au québec ou ailleurs
au canada
alors c'est un marché commun d'enfants
un marché commun qui devrait être
appelée à s'étendre
même au delà de l'amérique du nord
jean-michel le prêt sera du canada
montréal et on va poursuivre avec vous
mon sort gérard on le voit les échanges
se font déjà entre le québec et la
californie liliane l'ontario qui va se
joint à ce marché c'est important c'est
très important ça apporte beaucoup plus
de profondeur de crédibilité aux marchés
du carbone canadienne nord-américain en
quelque sorte et c'est important pour
l'environnement aussi en amérique du
nord au canada aux états unis trois
choses à dire là dessus le marché du
carbone
le signal du prix la tendance est lourde
en ce moment on veut tarifs et le
carbone c'est vrai en asie c'est vrai en
europe c'est de plus en plus vrai chez
nous deuxièmement le marché permet une
réduction graduelle des émissions de gaz
à effet de serre on peut pas arrêter
d'un coup sec des industries des
entreprises de fonctionner surtout parmi
les grands émetteurs le marché permet de
réduire graduellement et troisièmement
la question du plafond le plafond comme
est et qui va baisser d'année en année
sur les émissions de gaz à effet de
serre par industrie ça fait une pression
financière sur les grands émetteurs pour
les encourager à émettre moins de gaz à
effet de serre ou à s'intéresser à des
technologies vertes et ça vient stimuler
la recherche le développement pour les
entreprises qui ont des solutions
techniques
gic verte il prit demeure peu élevé le
prix demeure peu élevé et c'est pour ça
l'importance de voir des nouveaux
acteurs entrer dans la smart phones
l'ontario alors au québec et la
californie c'est une bourse du carbone
de mai 2013 on est en 10 et 15 dollars
la tonne s'il va falloir que ça monte un
peu la tonne de co2 l'alberta a misé sur
des échanges de crédits mais sur un
petit nombre d'entreprises et la
colombie-britannique mise plutôt sur une
taxe carbone fixe de 30 dollars la tonne